yes Martin we are in the your Vic Viking
Center one of York's biggest tourist
attractions of course another flood
victim in this city unfortunately and
that is the picture that we've seen
across York through the course of the
day people finally been get being able
to get back into their properties into
their businesses often some very sad
sites people trying to work out how they
go about clearing out but many people
pitching in and helping out this museum
of course will be familiar to many
people who would have visited 400,000
people visit every year sarah Maltby is
from the center Sarah you've been hit so
you've got a lot of water in in here
we're quite low down in this building
are we when did this start to come in
for you
well Sunday Sunday when we sort of first
noticed because we've got an overflow
from the foss in our back delivery yard
and basically it started sort of pouring
down there
we built a barrier at that point which
was very lucky and then that held back
the water for quite a number of hours
actually
but then overnight on Sunday started
coming up with floors through the walls
and we ended up Monday morning with
between half a meter meter and a half in
the attraction because stay is
underground and it's at a level and yes
we're now full of water this attraction
for those of you who haven't been here
recreates York as it was in Viking times
let's walk around the carousel here this
is how people get around this attraction
they get into these capsules and have an
audio tour they get the smells of what
it was like in Viking times in York but
as you can see just through here the
water is just right there it's about
four foot deep or so and this extends
throughout the basement of this
attraction Sarah how does it feel seeing
all this it's hard to put it into words
I must admit it's it's quite depressing
I would say you know it's it's a mess
isn't it it's a yeah and it's gonna take
some work to get it back to where we
were so yeah it's it's it's not a great
sight is it and the reality is that this
is going to probably have to be stripped
out isn't it you'll have to start again
with the attraction you've got people
booked in for for the new year
yeah we have we've got schools we've got
visitor you know international visitors
visitors from around here but all booked
in whoo we're getting in touch with now
and but we are not going to be open
obviously we can send people to our
other attractions it's not your Vic but
we can do that a lot of schools
obviously come to us every year and
we've got loads of schools booked in for
the new year so we'll try and do
something for them we'll try and do
something different something Viking
related for them you know we have the
resources here to do something somewhere
else perhaps but you know we've got a
long road ahead of us I think to get
this back to where it was and just a
final thought perhaps your city other
cities in the north are the town's other
villages this is so widespread this
batch of flooding isn't it how do you
try and kind of make sense of what's
happened in the last few days well it's
really hard isn't it I mean you know
we've never seen anything of this scale
anyway you know with the foss going as
well as use yes we're used to the use
bursting its banks virtually every year
and the Derwent as well around here you
know we used to that but nothing on this
scale and you know to see the people and
the houses and you know we've got loads
of members of staff that have been
affected obviously they've been
evacuated and trying to help them and be
supportive as well it's it's just
unbelievable really
okay so we'll leave it there but thank
you very much for joining us and letting
us in to have a look at the damage
inside here and as I say much of it will
have to be stripped out the good news
amongst all this is that the river
levels in New York are dropping today
it's been quite significant and part of
that is down to the fact the foss
barrier this turkey bit of
infrastructure on the river network that
had been out of action has now that
started to come back online four of the
eight pumps there are working again the
Environment Agency have told us which of
course it's good news what's not so good
as this next weather system that is due
to come in to the north of England and
Northern Ireland North Wales southern
parts of Scotland over the course of
tonight's storm Frank as it is called it
is again gonna bring heavy winds and
also heavy rain to parts of the UK that
already have had their fill of flooding
over the past month or so Martin